selamat kembali ke kursus Memahami Maklumat dan Pengiraan Kuantum nama saya John Watrous dan saya ialah pengarah teknikal untuk pendidikan di IBM
Quantum ini ialah pelajaran ke-10 siri ini dan merupakan pelajaran kedua dalam unit ketiga yang berkaitan dengan formulasi umum
maklumat kuantum pelajaran ini adalah tentang saluran yang mewakili perubahan dalam
sistem yang menyimpan maklumat kuantum ini termasuk operasi yang berguna seperti yang dilakukan oleh
gate uniter dan circuit kuantum serta perubahan yang mungkin kita lebih suka elakkan seperti hingar kita juga boleh menerangkan pengukuran
sebagai saluran dan itu adalah sesuatu yang akan kita masuki dalam pelajaran seterusnya istilah saluran datang kepada kita dari
teori maklumat yang antara lain mengkaji kapasiti pembawa maklumat saluran komunikasi yang bising
jadi apabila kita berfikir tentang saluran kita berfikir secara abstrak tentang saluran komunikasi
mungkin nampak agak pelik untuk fikirkan pengiraan yang rumit sebagai saluran komunikasi tetapi kita perlukan
satu perkataan untuk merujuk kepada konsep umum proses yang mengubah maklumat dengan cara tertentu dan suka atau tidak perkataan
saluran telah melekat tidak diragukan lagi sebahagian besarnya disebabkan oleh impak besar yang diberikan oleh teori maklumat dan khususnya
kerja Claude Shannon pada tahun 1940-an terhadap maklumat dan pengiraan kuantum berikut ialah gambaran keseluruhan
pelajaran ini kita akan mulakan dengan asas termasuk definisi apa itu saluran serta bagaimana operasi uniter dalam formulasi ringkas
maklumat kuantum boleh diterangkan sebagai saluran kita juga akan bincangkan fakta bahawa kombinasi cembung saluran adalah saluran dan jika kau
tertanya-tanya mengapa konsep kecembungan ini terus muncul itu kerana ia memang merupakan konsep matematik yang sangat penting secara asasnya dalam teori
maklumat kuantum kita juga akan melihat beberapa contoh saluran khususnya saluran qubit yang akan muncul semula dari masa
ke masa sepanjang baki pelajaran ini dalam bahagian kedua pelajaran kita akan bincangkan tiga cara berbeza yang boleh kita gunakan untuk mewakili saluran
secara matematik dan khususnya kita akan bincangkan perwakilan Stinespring perwakilan Krauss dan perwakilan Choi
yang dinamakan sempena tiga orang yang kerjanya penting dalam pembangunan perwakilan berbeza ini dan dalam bahagian ketiga dan
akhir pelajaran kita akan bincangkan bukti matematik yang menetapkan bahawa tiga perwakilan ini sebenarnya setara serta fakta bahawa ia
semua mencirikan dengan tepat definisi apa itu saluran ia merupakan bukti matematik yang sangat keren pada pendapat saya dan diharapkan ia akan menambah sedikit
kejelasan kepada pembentangan yang berbeza ini bagaimana ia berkait dan bagaimana ia berfungsi secara umum kita akan mulakan dengan asas dan
menjawab soalan apakah itu saluran seperti yang telah saya cadangkan di awal pelajaran saluran menerangkan perubahan
khususnya perubahan masa diskret dalam sistem yang menyimpan maklumat kuantum di sini apabila kita merujuk kepada perubahan masa diskret
kita hanya berfikir tentang perubahan yang berlaku antara dua detik masa yang berbeza berbanding
proses berterusan misalnya yang masuk akal untuk difikirkan dalam tempoh masa yang infinitesimally kecil saluran termasuk operasi yang berguna seperti
operasi uniter yang dilakukan oleh gate dan circuit kuantum serta perubahan akibat hingar misalnya untuk
tujuan pelajaran ini bagaimanapun kita kebanyakannya akan berfikir tentang saluran dalam istilah matematik abstrak dan tidak akan ada keperluan khusus
untuk membezakan antara apa yang berguna dan apa yang tidak nama biasa untuk saluran termasuk huruf Greek huruf besar fi
psi dan tao dan kita akan menggunakan huruf berbeza untuk merujuk kepada beberapa saluran tertentu dalam situasi mudah di mana
kita ada sistem yang berada dalam keadaan yang diterangkan oleh matriks ketumpatan rho dan kita kenakan saluran fi pada sistem itu
hasilnya adalah sistem yang keadaannya diterangkan oleh matriks ketumpatan fi rho jadi kita berfikir tentang
saluran fi tertentu sebagai fungsi yang boleh dikenakan pada matriks ketumpatan bersaiz tertentu atau dalam erti kata lain
matriks ketumpatan sistem tertentu yang kita kenakan saluran ini ada beberapa keperluan yang perlu dipenuhi oleh saluran untuk dianggap sebagai
saluran yang sah pertama saluran adalah pemetaan linear ini sepenuhnya analog dengan situasi yang kita ada dalam
formulasi ringkas maklumat kuantum di mana operasi pada vektor keadaan kuantum semestinya linear sebagai
mana juga dalam formulasi piawai maklumat klasik di mana operasi kebarangkalian adalah linear kau boleh mempersoalkan
keperluan asas kelinearan ini jika kau benar-benar mahu tetapi jika kita mahukan teori yang konsisten dengan kedua-dua teori kebarangkalian
dan pilihan untuk mewakili keadaan kuantum dengan matriks ketumpatan maka kita tidak mempunyai sebarang pilihan dan kita hanya perlu menerima bahawa saluran adalah linear
keperluan kedua ialah saluran menukar matriks ketumpatan kepada matriks ketumpatan itu masuk akal sepenuhnya kerana jika kita telah memilih untuk mewakili
keadaan sistem dengan matriks ketumpatan dan kita kenakan saluran pada sistem yang berada dalam sesetengah keadaan maka hasilnya mestilah keadaan yang sah dan oleh itu
diwakili oleh matriks ketumpatan ada satu perkara sangat penting yang perlu ditambah di sini iaitu keperluan ini
mestilah benar bukan sahaja jika kita kenakan saluran kepada sistem terpencil yang keadaannya diterangkan oleh matriks ketumpatan
tetapi juga jika kita ada sistem majmuk yang keadaannya diterangkan oleh beberapa matriks ketumpatan dan kita kenakan saluran hanya pada
sebahagian daripada sistem itu jadi itulah keperluan yang kita letakkan pada saluran dan kita boleh lihat bahawa ia sangat
analog dengan keperluan yang kita ada untuk operasi dalam formulasi ringkas maklumat kuantum dan formulasi piawai
maklumat klasik dalam formulasi ringkas maklumat kuantum operasi diwakili oleh matriks uniter kerana ia
sepadan tepat dengan pemetaan linear yang sentiasa menukar vektor keadaan kuantum kepada vektor keadaan kuantum untuk
sistem tertentu dan begitu juga operasi kebarangkalian diwakili oleh matriks stokastik kerana itulah yang sentiasa
menukar vektor kebarangkalian kepada vektor kebarangkalian di sini kita bekerja dengan matriks ketumpatan dan ada
keperluan tambahan mengenai sistem majmuk ini yang ternyata tidak perlu untuk vektor keadaan kuantum
atau vektor kebarangkalian tetapi selainnya keperluan itu adalah analog dan dalam erti tertentu dipaksakan kepada kita oleh pilihan
untuk mewakili keadaan kuantum dengan matriks ketumpatan berikut ialah beberapa butiran lanjut tentang saluran termasuk konvensyen
untuk bagaimana kita akan fikirkan sistem input dan output sesuatu saluran sepanjang pelajaran ini serta beberapa butiran lanjut
tentang keperluan bahawa saluran sentiasa menukar matriks ketumpatan kepada matriks ketumpatan pertama setiap saluran
dianggap mempunyai sistem input dan sistem output kita boleh namakan sistem ini sesuka hati tetapi sepanjang
pelajaran ini saya akan menggunakan nama X untuk merujuk kepada sistem input dan nama y untuk merujuk kepada sistem output secara konsepsual saluran
menukar sistem input kepada sistem output jadi sistem input dan output tidak pernah wujud serentak kita
mulakan dengan x saluran dikenakan atau dilakukan dan hasilnya ialah X telah ditukar kepada y yang keadaannya
ditentukan oleh pemetaan linear yang dikaitkan dengan saluran itu sistem input dan output bagi saluran tidak perlu sama dan khususnya
ia tidak perlu mempunyai bilangan keadaan klasik yang sama bagaimanapun boleh jadi bahawa sistem input dan output sebenarnya sistem yang sama atau dalam erti kata lain
WEBVTT
x sama dengan y dalam kes itu kita hanya membayangkan bahawa fi sedang mengubah keadaan sistem dan memang ini adalah
situasi yang sering kita minati tetapi kemungkinan ini konsisten dengan perkara pertama dalam ertinya kita tidak pernah ada
sistem input dan output wujud sebagai dua sistem berasingan pada masa yang sama dan dalam apa jua kes ia akan lebih mudah untuk
tujuan pelajaran ini menggunakan huruf berbeza iaitu X dan Y untuk merujuk kepada sistem input dan output
hanya untuk membantu kita kekalkan benda yang betul sekarang jom masuk sedikit lebih terperinci tentang keperluan bahawa saluran sentiasa menukar matriks
ketumpatan kepada matriks ketumpatan jom katakan bahawa kita memperkenalkan sistem baru Z ke dalam gambar jom
berikan nama gamma kepada set keadaan klasik sistem baru ini bayangkan sekarang bahawa kita membentuk sistem majmuk baru ZX
yang terdiri daripada sistem baru bersama sistem input X saluran fi dan katakan sistem majmuk ini berada dalam
keadaan yang diterangkan oleh matriks ketumpatan rho ini boleh menjadi keadaan kuantum sewenang-wenang bagi pasangan ini tetapi apa pun keadaannya
ia sentiasa mungkin untuk menyatakan matriks ketumpatan rho dalam bentuk yang ditunjukkan di skrin di mana A dan B kedua-duanya
berkisar ke atas set keadaan klasik gamma dan setiap rho AB adalah beberapa matriks yang baris dan lajurnya sepadan dengan apa pun
set keadaan klasik X dan kita tidak perlu memberikan nama kepada set keadaan klasik itu pada ketika ini untuk jelaskan setiap rho AB bukan semestinya
matriks ketumpatan sendiri tetapi matriks rho keseluruhan semestinya matriks ketumpatan apabila kita kenakan saluran fi pada
sistem X ia ditukar kepada Y dan jadi kita tinggal dengan pasangan zy dan cara kita menentukan
keadaan pasangan ini selepas menjalankan fi hanya pada X ialah menilai pemetaan linear fi pada setiap matriks rho a
cara lain untuk mengatakannya ialah kita mengambil hasil darab tensor pemetaan fi dengan pemetaan identiti pada matriks segiempat sama yang mempunyai baris dan lajur
yang sepadan dengan gamma dan itu seterusnya sepadan dengan tidak melakukan apa-apa kepada sistem baru Z ini tetapi ini adalah penerangan yang setara
dan ia tidak memerlukan penjelasan tentang hasil darab tensor pemetaan berbentuk ini
ia bagaimanapun berfungsi dengan cara yang cukup mudah yang analog dengan cara ia berfungsi untuk vektor dan matriks satu cara untuk fikirkan tentang ini secara visual adalah
dalam bentuk matriks blok dan jika kita membuat andaian penyederhanaan bahawa set keadaan klasik gamma terdiri daripada
integer antara 0 dan N tolak satu untuk sesetengah integer positif M maka ia menjadi mudah untuk menulis semua ini seperti yang
ditunjukkan di sini dan sekarang untuk mengulangi keperluan yang kita letakkan pada fi agar ia menjadi saluran yang sah kita mesti sentiasa mendapat matriks
ketumpatan daripada proses ini dan ini mestilah benar tanpa mengira pilihan yang kita buat untuk sistem Z serta
pilihan yang kita buat untuk rho dengan syarat ia adalah matriks ketumpatan itu mungkin nampak seperti keperluan yang cukup ketat dan ia
juga mungkin nampak sangat sukar untuk disemak tetapi seperti yang akan kita lihat menjelang akhir pelajaran ia sebenarnya tidak begitu ketat
atau sukar untuk disemak dan khususnya kita ada pencirian matematik yang bagus untuk syarat ini
yang berkaitan dengan perwakilan berbeza yang akan kita bincangkan sedikit kemudian dalam pelajaran ini sekarang jom tengok beberapa contoh saluran
mulai dengan keseluruhan kategori saluran yang dipanggil saluran uniter dalam istilah mudah ini adalah operasi uniter
sama seperti yang kita ada dalam formulasi ringkas maklumat kuantum yang dilihat sebagai saluran untuk tepatnya katakan U adalah matriks uniter
yang mewakili operasi uniter pada sistem X jadi dalam formulasi ringkas maklumat kuantum
kita akan darab matriks ini kepada vektor keadaan kuantum yang diberi untuk menentukan tindakan yang dimiliki oleh operasi itu pada keadaan kuantum itu cara
ini berfungsi untuk matriks ketumpatan ialah kita darab matriks ketumpatan di sebelah kiri oleh U dan di sebelah kanan oleh U
dagger dalam istilah matematik kita merujuk operasi ini sebagai konjugasi oleh Matriks U ini konsisten dengan ket psi
bra psi menjadi matriks ketumpatan yang menerangkan keadaan yang diwakili oleh vektor keadaan kuantum psi dan ia adalah cukup
mudah untuk semak bahawa khususnya jika kita menjalankan U pada vektor keadaan kuantum ket psi kita akan mendapat U kali ket psi dan perwakilan
matriks ketumupatannya diberikan oleh vektor itu kali transpos konjugatnya iaitu U kali ket psi kali bra psi kali U
dagger apabila kita menilai transpos konjugat U kali ket psi jadi cara saluran ini ditakrifkan
masuk akal untuk keadaan tulen dan apabila kita gabungkan ini dengan kelinearan kita lihat bahawa ia masuk akal untuk matriks ketumpatan secara
umum kerana hakikat bahawa setiap matriks ketumpatan boleh dinyatakan sebagai kombinasi cembung keadaan tulen definisi ini
sentiasa memberikan kita saluran yang sah untuk mana-mana pilihan operasi uniter u khususnya mengkonjugat dengan
matriks uniter seperti ini tidak mengubah surih matriks dan jika kita mengkonjugat mana-mana matriks separa positif definitif
dengan mana-mana matriks kita akan mendapat matriks separa positif definitif yang lain dan ia cukup mudah untuk mendapat itu
secara langsung daripada definisi matriks separa positif definitif jadi matriks ketumpatan sentiasa dipetakan kepada matriks
ketumpatan dan semua ini tetap benar walaupun jika kita tensor u dengan matriks identiti bersaiz apa-apa yang setara dengan
mengenakan saluran ini hanya pada sebahagian daripada sistem majmuk berikut ialah contoh yang sangat mudah bagi saluran uniter katakan kita
ambil U itu sendiri sebagai matriks identiti ini adalah saluran yang sah yang sangat jelas dipanggil saluran identiti melakukan
tiada apa pun sama sekali memang operasi linear dan jika kita mulakan dengan matriks ketumpatan dan kita tidak melakukan apa-apa padanya ia
masih akan menjadi matriks ketumpatan jadi ini adalah saluran yang sah orang menggunakan simbol berbeza untuk menandakan saluran ini
kadang-kadang ia adalah tepat simbol yang sama yang kita gunakan untuk matriks identiti yang boleh menjadi sedikit mengelirukan tetapi biasanya tidak di sini saya menggunakan
huruf ID ringkasan untuk identiti hanya untuk mengelakkan kekeliruan dan notasi ini juga agak biasa mungkin nampak seperti
saluran yang sangat membosankan tetapi dalam konteks penghantaran maklumat ia sebenarnya saluran yang sempurna di mana
penerima mendapat tepat apa yang penghantar hantar yang biasanya paling diinginkan dalam konteks itu cara lain kita boleh
mendapatkan banyak contoh saluran ialah dengan mengambil kombinasi cembung saluran atau dalam erti kata lain meratakan ia
bersama-sama dan fakta bahawa kita boleh berbuat demikian merupakan aspek penting saluran untuk menerangkan ini dengan lebih terperinci jom mulakan dengan dua saluran fi0 dan fi1 katakanlah
bersama nombor nyata P antara 0 dan satu dan untuk jelaskan kita mengandaikan bahawa dua saluran ini mempunyai
sistem input yang sama iaitu X serta sistem output yang sama iaitu y dan sekarang pertimbangkan apa yang berlaku jika kita memutuskan
untuk mengenakan saluran pertama fi0 dengan kebarangkalian p dan jika tidak dengan kebarangkalian yang tinggal 1 tolak p kita kenakan
saluran kedua fi1 misalnya mungkin kita memilih bit secara rawak dengan kebarangkalian tersebut dan kemudian gunakan bit rawak ini
untuk menentukan saluran mana yang akan dikenakan dengan berbuat demikian kita secara efektif mengenakan saluran baru yang mungkin kita panggil psi
yang diberikan oleh kombinasi cembung dua saluran yang kita mulakan dengannya dan yang boleh kita nyatakan seperti yang ditulis
di skrin kita sentiasa boleh mengambil gabungan linear pemetaan linear seperti ini by the way dan cara gabungan linear
WEBVTT
pemetaan linear ditakrifkan pada input yang diberi ialah kita hanya mengambil gabungan linear yang sama bagi output
itu mungkin kelihatan agak remeh tetapi ia masuk akal output yang kita dapat daripada senario hipotetikal ini hanyalah purata berwajaran
output yang kita akan dapat daripada dua saluran asal walaupun begitu ini adalah saluran baru dan
jika fi0 dan fi1 adalah saluran yang sah maka sudah pasti pemetaan baru ini juga akan menjadi saluran yang sah cara lain untuk mengatakannya
dalam istilah matematik ialah set semua saluran dari sistem input tertentu ke sistem output tertentu adalah
cembung dan itu merupakan sifat matematik penting bagi saluran kita boleh lakukan ini secara lebih umum jika kita ada M saluran fi 0 hingga fi m tolak satu katakanlah
bersama vektor kebarangkalian yang memberitahu kita apakah kebarangkalian untuk setiap saluran maka kita mendapat saluran baru dengan meratakan saluran tersebut sewajarnya jadi
dalam erti tertentu ini adalah sumber tanpa henti saluran baru misalnya kelas saluran uniter bercampur yang dipanggil adalah yang
kita dapat dengan mengambil kombinasi cembung saluran uniter iaitu jika kita ada M matriks uniter u0 hingga u m tolak
satu yang semua bersaiz sama bersama vektor kebarangkalian maka jika kita mengambil purata berwajaran saluran
yang sepadan dengan matriks uniter individu seperti yang ditunjukkan di sini di skrin maka kita akan mendapat saluran dan saluran
yang boleh ditulis seperti ini dipanggil saluran uniter bercampur bukan setiap saluran adalah saluran uniter bercampur kita tidak boleh mendapat
setiap saluran dengan cara ini tetapi ia memang muncul agak kerap seterusnya kita akan tengok beberapa
contoh spesifik saluran ini semua akan menjadi contoh saluran dari satu qubit ke satu qubit yang dipanggil saluran
qubit secara ringkas yang pertama dipanggil saluran set semula qubit dan ideanya ialah saluran ini menetapkan semula qubit
kepada keadaan sifar di sini kita menggunakan huruf Greek huruf besar Lambda untuk menandakan saluran ini dan cara kau boleh ingat apa yang saluran ini lakukan ialah
fikirkan tentang sfera Bloch Lambda huruf besar macam anak panah menghala ke atas dan keadaan sifar berada di bahagian atas sfera Bloch jadi ia seolah-olah
menunjuk ke lokasi output cara ia ditakrifkan dalam istilah matematik ialah Lambda rho bersamaan surih rho kali ket 0 bra 0 jadi
jika kita nilaikan pada mana-mana matriks ketumpatan rho kita akan mendapat keadaan sifar sebagai matriks ketumpatan ia wajar untuk tertanya-tanya
mengapa kita perlukan surih tidakkah kita boleh hanya takrifkan Lambda rho sebagai ket sifar bra sifar tanpa surih rho di hadapan
dan jawapan kepada soalan itu ialah tidak saluran perlu menjadi pemetaan linear dan ia tidak akan linear jika kita buang surih rho perlu juga diingat bahawa
kadang-kadang kita perlu tahu bagaimana saluran berfungsi sebagai pemetaan linear pada input matriks bukan ketumpatan misalnya seperti yang
kita lihat sebelumnya jika kita nak tahu apa yang saluran lakukan apabila kita kenakan ia pada sistem majmuk kita perlu
menilai saluran itu pada blok individu matriks blok yang lebih besar dan walaupun matriks blok keseluruhan mungkin
matriks ketumpatan blok individu secara umum tidak akan begitu jom tengok tepat apa yang saluran ini lakukan apabila kita kenakan ia
pada hanya satu bahagian sistem majmuk dan lebih khusus apa yang ia lakukan apabila kita kenakan ia pada satu daripada dua qubit yang
membentuk ebit untuk tepatnya katakan A dan B adalah qubit yang sebagai pasangan berada dalam keadaan Bell fi plus dan kita kenakan Lambda
katakanlah pada qubit pertama a untuk mengetahui apa yang berlaku jom mula-mula nyatakan keadaan fi plus sebagai matriks ketumpatan dan
untuk kepentingan contoh ini jom gunakan notasi langsung untuk melakukan itu berikut ialah keadaan fi plus sebagai vektor keadaan kuantum dan berikut ialah yang kita dapat apabila kita
darab vektor ini dengan transpos konjugatnya dan mengembangkannya semuanya kita kemudian boleh kenakan saluran pada qubit pertama dan nilaikan yang kita dapat berikut ialah
Lambda yang dikenakan pada qubit pertama dan berikut ialah yang kita dapat apabila kita nilaikan setiap suku itu surih ket 0 bra 0 adalah satu
begitu juga surih ket 1 bra 1 jadi dalam dua kes itu output saluran adalah ket 0 bra 0 dan itu menerangkan
dua suku dalam jawapan surih ket sifar bra satu di pihak lain adalah sifar begitu juga surih ket 1 bra sifar
dan jadi dua suku itu menjadi sifar dan oleh itu tidak menyumbang apa-apa kepada jawapan kita kini boleh permudahkan sedikit
dan apa yang kita dapat ialah keadaan sifar untuk qubit pertama iaitu a dan keadaan bercampur sepenuhnya untuk
qubit kedua iaitu B perhatikan khususnya bahawa kita tidak mendapat keadaan plus untuk B yang tidak semestinya
menjadi teka-teki yang buruk jika kita tidak tahu apa-apa tentang matriks ketumpatan dan kita hanya melihat perwakilan vektor keadaan kuantum bagi keadaan itu tetapi itulah
bukan cara saluran ini berfungsi dan tiada saluran yang mungkin boleh berfungsi dengan cara itu saluran Lambda dipanggil saluran set semula qubit tetapi
cara ia berfungsi lebih seperti membuang qubit input ke dalam tong sampah dan menggantikannya dengan qubit segar dalam keadaan sifar tetapi ini sebenarnya adalah
satu-satunya saluran qubit yang sentiasa menghasilkan keadaan sifar berikut ialah contoh lain saluran qubit yang dikenali sebagai
saluran penyahfasa sepenuhnya saluran ini ditandakan oleh Delta dan cara ia berfungsi ialah ia membiarkan entri pepenjuru
mana-mana matriks 2x2 tidak berubah dan menzirofkan entri luar pepenjuru Delta adalah huruf Greek setara dengan D dalam
abjad Latin dan itu singkatan untuk pepenjuru jadi itulah satu cara untuk ingat apa yang saluran ini lakukan kita boleh
juga nyatakan saluran ini secara alternatif menggunakan notasi langsung seperti yang ditunjukkan di skrin dan untuk jelaskan output
adalah sentiasa matriks 2x2 jadi khususnya dua output sifar merujuk kepada matriks 2x2 sifar semua kita selalu
lakukan ini dan kita dah lihat ini sebelum dalam siri ini simbol sifar biasanya digunakan mungkin secara samar-samar untuk bermakna unsur sifar
apa pun yang kita bicarakan sama ada skalar vektor matriks atau apa sahaja jom lakukan perkara yang sama yang kita lakukan sebelumnya untuk
saluran set semula qubit dan lihat apa yang berlaku jika kita kenakan saluran ini pada separuh ebit persediaan adalah sama jadi saya tidak akan lalui
bahagian itu dan hasilnya adalah keadaan yang ditunjukkan di skrin yang pada dasarnya merupakan bit rawak yang dikongsi jadi apa
yang saluran ini lakukan pada dasarnya ialah menukar ebit kepada pasangan bit rawak klasik yang berkorelasi dengan sempurna
dan itu konsisten dengan tafsiran lebih umum saluran ini dengan menzirofkan entri luar pepenjuru matriks ketumpatan kita secara efektif
membuang benda kuantum dalam matriks ketumpatan meninggalkan matriks ketumpatan pepenjuru yang mewakili
keadaan kebarangkalian klasik cara lain untuk fikirkan tentang ini ialah saluran ini mewakili saluran klasik sempurna tanpa hingar yang menghantar bit
jadi jika kita masukkan keadaan sifar atau keadaan satu atau kombinasi cembung dua keadaan itu ke dalam saluran maka keadaan itu keluar tidak berubah tetapi jika kau cuba
memasukkan keadaan kuantum ke dalamnya seperti keadaan plus misalnya ia seolah-olah saluran mengukur keadaan itu dengan pengukuran asas piawai dan kemudian
menghantar hasilnya secara klasik contoh terakhir saluran qubit ialah saluran depolarisasi sepenuhnya apa
yang saluran ini lakukan ialah sentiasa menghasilkan keadaan bercampur sepenuhnya jadi ia serupa dalam erti tertentu dengan saluran set semula qubit
kecuali kita mendapat keadaan bercampur sepenuhnya yang agak kurang berguna dan bukannya qubit yang diinisialisasi cara yang semulajadi
untuk fikirkan tentang saluran ini ialah ia mewakili bentuk hingar yang ekstrem dan sejauh mana saluran qubit berkaitan
ia tidak boleh menjadi lebih bising daripada ini saya tidak ada mnemonik yang baik untuk berkongsi bagi mengingati apa yang saluran ini lakukan selain daripada mengatakan bahawa Omega adalah huruf terakhir
abjad Greek dan ia kadang-kadang dikaitkan dengan penghujung segala-galanya dan mungkin inilah yang berlaku
WEBVTT
kepada semua qubit akhirnya sejauh mana hingar pergi ia cukup ekstrem tetapi satu perkara yang boleh kita lakukan ialah mempertimbangkan kombinasi cembung
saluran ini dan saluran identiti dengan mungkin kebarangkalian kecil epsilon untuk
depolarisasi sepenuhnya ini adalah bentuk hingar yang kurang ekstrem di mana keadaan qubit tertentu kebanyakannya akan dibiarkan sahaja tetapi ada
peluang kecil bahawa ia menjadi bercampur sepenuhnya secara geometri kita boleh fikirkan tentang ini sebagai pengecutan sedikit sfera Bloch ke arah tengah
dan by the way kita boleh melakukan sesuatu yang serupa dengan saluran penyahfasa sepenuhnya untuk memodelkan proses dekoherensi misalnya di mana benda
menjadi sedikit lebih klasik melalui sesetengah proses jadi itulah tiga contoh asas saluran qubit dan kita akan
kembali kepada mereka terutamanya sebagai sumber contoh sepanjang baki pelajaran ini seterusnya kita akan bincangkan perwakilan matematik
saluran mulai dengan soalan asas pemetaan linear dari vektor ke vektor sentiasa boleh
diwakili oleh matriks dengan cara yang biasa iaitu tindakan pemetaan linear diterangkan oleh
pendaraban matriks vektor tetapi saluran adalah pemetaan linear dari matriks ke matriks bukan vektor ke vektor jadi secara
umum bagaimana kita boleh menyatakan saluran dalam istilah matematik kadang-kadang untuk saluran khas kita akan ada formula mudah
yang menerangkannya dan itulah kes dalam contoh saluran qubit yang telah kita bincangkan tetapi itu tidak
praktikal secara umum kerana tidak sentiasa ada formula yang bagus sebagai perbandingan dalam formulasi ringkas
maklumat kuantum kita menggunakan matriks uniter untuk mewakili operasi pada vektor keadaan kuantum
setiap matriks uniter mewakili operasi yang sah dan setiap operasi yang sah boleh dinyatakan sebagai matriks uniter jadi pada
dasarnya apa yang soalan ini tanya ialah bagaimana kita lakukan ini untuk saluran dan jawapan kepada soalan ini ialah sebenarnya ada beberapa cara untuk mewakili
saluran dalam istilah matematik khususnya kita akan bincangkan tiga cara berbeza untuk mewakili saluran yang
dinamakan sempena tiga individu yang kerjanya memainkan peranan penting dalam pembangunannya Stinespring Krauss dan Choi
pertama kita akan lihat bagaimana perwakilan berbeza ini berfungsi dan kemudian dalam bahagian terakhir pelajaran kita akan lihat bagaimana tiga perwakilan itu berkait dan
khususnya bagaimana kita boleh menukar antara ia kita juga akan lihat bahawa perwakilan ini menangkap dengan tepat keperluan yang kita ada pada saluran
iaitu bahawa ia adalah pemetaan linear dan bahawa ia sentiasa menukar matriks ketumpatan kepada matriks ketumpatan walaupun
ia dikenakan hanya pada sebahagian daripada sistem majmuk pertama sekali ialah perwakilan Stinespring Willam Forest Stinespring
ialah seorang ahli matematik yang tidak bekerja pada maklumat kuantum dan perwakilan Stinespring seperti yang akan saya huraikan
dalam erti tertentu hanyalah terbitan kerjanya tentang teori operator pada tahun 1950-an tetapi kerja ini pasti
merupakan bahagian penting pembangunan matematik yang saluran kuantum adalah berdasarkan idea di sebalik cara mewakili saluran ini ialah setiap
saluran boleh dilaksanakan dengan cara tertentu yang akan saya huraikan sekarang pertama kita membentuk sistem majmuk yang terdiri daripada
input kepada saluran yang kita laksanakan bersama sistem ruang kerja yang diinisialisasi kemudian
operasi uniter dilakukan pada sistem majmuk itu dan akhirnya bahagian mana pun sistem majmuk yang terhasil
yang sepadan dengan output saluran dibiarkan sahaja atau dikeluarkan dan baki dibuang atau disurihi adalah membantu untuk
menyatakan ini dalam bentuk gambar rajah dan ia paling mudah untuk mulakan dengan kes khas di mana sistem input dan
output adalah sama gambar rajah ini by the way adalah seperti gambar rajah circuit kuantum kecuali bahawa wayar
mewakili sistem sewenang-wenang dan bukan semestinya qubit tunggal jadi kita mulakan dengan sistem input X yang berada dalam sesetengah
keadaan rho kita memperkenalkan sistem ruang kerja W yang diinisialisasi dan dalam gambar rajah ini saya mengandaikan bahawa Sifar adalah keadaan klasik
w dan kita mengambil ket 0 sebagai keadaan yang diinisialisasi sistem itu tetapi kita boleh secara alternatif menetapkan mana-mana keadaan tulen
w dan melihat itu sebagai keadaan yang diinisialisasi kita kemudian menjalankan beberapa operasi uniter pada pasangan WX dan kemudian
surihi sistem ruang kerja dan keluarkan X di sini dalam gambar rajah by the way saya menggunakan simbol bumi dari
kejuruteraan elektrik untuk menunjukkan bahawa W sedang dibuang itu tidak semestinya konvensional dan kau tidak akan
menemui simbol tersebut dalam Qiskit di sana kau hanya abaikan qubit yang kau tidak minati intinya ialah saya hanya mahu ada simbol yang membuatkannya
jelas bahawa kita membuang sistem untuk tujuan perbincangan ini secara umum kita tidak semestinya perlukan
sistem input dan output adalah sama jadi kita boleh ada misalnya sistem output y bersama sistem sampah
G yang disurihi agar U menjadi uniter ia mesti menjadi matriks segiempat sama jadi ada andaian
di sini bahawa pasangan g y bersama mempunyai bilangan keadaan klasik yang sama dengan pasangan WX misalnya mungkin sistem ini
terdiri daripada qubit dan sistem input X terdiri daripada 5 qubit dan W terdiri daripada 10 qubit katakanlah jadi U adalah operasi uniter
pada 15 qubit kemudian boleh jadi bahawa y hanya terdiri daripada empat qubit yang bermakna g terdiri daripada 11 qubit
atau mungkin ini bukan qubit sama sekali yang penting ialah bahawa WX bersama dan gy bersama mempunyai bilangan
keadaan klasik yang sama supaya U boleh uniter penerangan saluran seperti ini dipanggil perwakilan Stinespring saluran itu sekarang ia
cukup mudah untuk berhujah bahawa mana-mana pemetaan fi yang boleh diterangkan dengan cara ini adalah sebenarnya saluran yang sah
khususnya jika kita mulakan dengan matriks ketumpatan dan kemudian tambahkan sistem ruang kerja tambahan maka kita pasti akan
tinggal dengan matriks ketumpatan kita dah perhatikan bahawa mengenakan operasi uniter memberikan kita saluran yang sah dan
jika kita ada matriks ketumpatan sistem majmuk dan kita surihi salah satu sistem maka sekali lagi kita akan tinggal dengan matriks ketumpatan jadi apabila kita gabungkan
langkah-langkah ini kita akan dijamin bahawa ia sentiasa menukar matriks ketumpatan kepada matriks ketumpatan dan ia juga linear
apa yang tidak jelas sama sekali pada ketika ini ialah bahawa setiap saluran memang boleh dilaksanakan dengan cara ini untuk sesetengah pilihan
sistem ruang kerja dan sistem sampah serta operasi uniter U tentu saja tetapi itu adalah benar dan kita akan
lihat mengapa menjelang akhir pelajaran berikut ialah contoh perwakilan Stinespring untuk saluran qubit penyahfasa
sepenuhnya dan untuk jelaskan sekarang wayar adalah qubit dan ini adalah gate NOT terkawal biasa
ia sangat mudah qubit input berada di atas dan kita memperkenalkan qubit ruang kerja yang diinisialisasi kepada keadaan sifar
kita kemudian menjalankan operasi NOT terkawal di mana qubit input adalah kawalan dan qubit ruang kerja adalah
sasaran dan kemudian qubit ruang kerja disurihi secara intuitif ia masuk akal
bahawa ini sepatutnya melaksanakan saluran penyahfasa sepenuhnya kerana gate NOT terkawal macam bertindak seperti pengukuran asas piawai pada
qubit atas dengan menyalin keadaan klasiknya ke qubit bawah dan kemudian hasilnya dibuang
tetapi kita juga boleh lalui pengiraan dan sudah tentu adalah idea yang baik untuk melakukan itu kerana kita benar-benar
WEBVTT
tidak sepatutnya terlalu mempercayai intuisi kita kita boleh mulakan dengan menulis perwakilan matriks ketumpatan dua
qubit selepas qubit ruang kerja diperkenalkan dan perhatikan bahawa kita menggunakan konvensyen pengaturan qubit seperti
biasa di mana qubit bawah berada di sebelah kiri dan qubit atas berada di sebelah kanan kita boleh nyatakan matriks ketumpatan ini
secara eksplisit sebagai matriks 4x4 sebenar seperti yang ditunjukkan di skrin dan kemudian kita kira kesan
yang dimiliki oleh gate NOT terkawal pada matriks ketumpatan ini jadi kita mengkonjugat dengan matriks uniter yang dikaitkan dengan
gate ini sekali lagi mengingati konvensyen pengaturan qubit jadi ini adalah matriks uniter yang betul
dan hasilnya ditunjukkan di sini pada hakikatnya gate NOT terkawal
menukar entri matriks asal kita sedikit jadi sekarang entri yang mungkin bukan sifar berada di
empat sudut masih ada untuk mengira surih separa dan kita boleh melakukannya secara langsung daripada matriks tetapi
alternatifnya ialah menukar kepada notasi langsung seperti yang ditunjukkan di skrin dan kemudian ia menjadi cukup mudah untuk nilaikan
apa yang berlaku apabila kita surihi qubit di sebelah kiri dalam setiap suku dan hasilnya ialah hanya
suku yang sepadan dengan entri pepenjuru rho yang bertahan dan jadi kita telah menyahfasa qubit seperti yang
dijangkakan seperti biasa semak ini sendiri pada kadar kau sendiri jika kau pilih untuk melakukannya ia adalah contoh yang baik
untuk mendapat latihan bekerja dengan matriks ketumpatan dan dengan surih
separa itu bukan satu-satunya cara untuk melaksanakan saluran penyahfasa sepenuhnya berikut ialah perwakilan Stinespring alternatif untuk saluran ini
saya tidak akan lalui pengiraan secara terperinci dalam video ini tetapi saya akan tunjukkan secara ringkas sekiranya kau ingin jeda video dan melihat dengan
lebih teliti cara ia berfungsi adalah serupa dengan yang pertama tetapi butirannya adalah
berbeza kali ini kita mulakan dengan gate Hadamard pada qubit ruang kerja yang meletakkannya dalam keadaan plus dan jika
kita kembangkan hasil darab tensor kita mendapat matriks yang ditunjukkan di skrin untuk mengenakan gate Z terkawal kita
mengkonjugat dengan matriks uniter yang berkaitan dan hasilnya daripada melakukan itu ialah menyuntikkan beberapa tanda tolak ke dalam
matriks khususnya baris terakhir dan lajur terakhir kedua-duanya didarab dengan negatif 1
dan kali ini ia akan agak melekit untuk menukar kepada notasi langsung jadi kita akan kira surih separa
secara langsung apabila kita surihi yang pertama daripada dua qubit apa yang kita akhirnya dapat ialah jumlah dua blok 2x2 pepenjuru
dan jadi keputusan akhirnya ialah sekali lagi bahawa kita telah menyahfasa qubit itu cepat dan jika kau tidak
biasa dengan jenis pengiraan ini maka ambil masa kau dan lakukannya perlahan-lahan kelajuan tidak penting
di sini untuk selesaikan contoh ini biar saya sebutkan bahawa ada idea yang cukup mudah di sebalik pelaksanaan ini yang
dinyatakan dengan cukup baik oleh langkah terakhir pengiraan yang baru kita ringkaskan cara yang lebih ringkas untuk mengatakannya
ialah jika kita meratakan matriks ketumpatan qubit tertentu dengan matriks ketumpatan itu yang dikonjugat oleh matriks Pauli Z maka
itu adalah sama dengan menyahfasa jadi saluran penyahfasa sepenuhnya kebetulan adalah saluran uniter
bercampur di mana kita sama ada tidak melakukan apa-apa atau dalam erti kata lain kita menjalankan operasi identiti atau kita menjalankan gate Z masing-masing
dengan kebarangkalian setengah bagus untuk diketahui jadi ringkasnya kita ada dua perwakilan Stinespring berbeza
bagi saluran penyahfasa sepenuhnya dan itu memberitahu kita sesuatu yang penting iaitu perwakilan Stinespring
tidak unik dan sebenarnya ada infiniti banyaknya untuk mana-mana saluran tertentu seterusnya kita bincangkan perwakilan Krauss
saluran yang memberikan kita cara formulaik yang mudah untuk menyatakan saluran melalui
pendaraban dan penambahan matriks perwakilan Krauss dinamakan sempena Karl Krauss yang merupakan seorang ahli fizik yang antara lain
mengerjakan banyak butiran matematik asas saluran dan formulasi umum maklumat kuantum secara lebih luas secara umum
perwakilan Krauss adalah ungkapan saluran yang mengambil bentuk yang ditunjukkan di sini di skrin khususnya kita ada
koleksi matriks yang di sini dinamakan a 0 hingga a n tolak satu untuk sesetengah integer positif n dan ia menentukan
tindakan saluran pada mana-mana input rho yang diberi mengikut formula secara ringkas kita mengkonjugat rho oleh setiap matriks ini
yang sering dirujuk sebagai matriks Krauss dalam konteks ini dan kemudian kita jumlahkan hasilnya dan itu memberikan kita output semua matriks ini perlu mempunyai
dimensi yang sama dan khususnya lajurnya mesti sepadan dengan keadaan klasik sistem input dan
barisnya mesti sepadan dengan keadaan klasik sistem output jika itu kes maka apabila kita mengambil hasil darab AK kali rho kali AK dagger untuk mana-mana
pilihan K kita mendapat matriks segiempat sama yang baris dan lajurnya sepadan dengan keadaan klasik sistem output
dan jadi masuk akal bahawa ungkapan itu menghasilkan matriks ketumpatan sistem output sekarang bukan kes
bahawa untuk pilihan sewenang-wenang matriks Krauss ini kita mendapat saluran yang sah bagaimanapun ada syarat yang cukup mudah
pada matriks yang menjamin kita akan mendapat saluran yang sah dan syarat itu adalah formula yang dipaparkan di sini
khususnya jika kita jumlahkan hasil darab AK dagger kali AK ke atas semua nilai K
maka kita mesti mendapat matriks identiti dan itu akan menjadi matriks identiti yang baris dan lajurnya sepadan dengan
keadaan klasik sistem input jadi syarat itu mesti dipenuhi agar pemetaan yang ditakrifkan oleh
persamaan pertama menjadi saluran yang sah dan rupa-rupanya setiap saluran memang mempunyai perwakilan yang mengambil
bentuk ini selagi kita ambil n cukup besar berikut ialah beberapa contoh perwakilan Krauss
bermula dengan saluran set semula qubit kita boleh mendapatkan perwakilan Krauss untuk saluran ini dengan menggunakan
dua matriks Krauss ket 0 bra 0 dan ket 0 bra satu jadi n sama dengan dua dalam contoh ini
kita boleh masukkan pilihan ini ke dalam formula umum dan kita hanya ada dua suku jadi mudah untuk menulis jumlah tersebut
dan jika kita permudahkan dan sedar bahawa ungkapan dalam kurungan adalah surih rho maka kita lihat bahawa kita mendapat
saluran set semula qubit kita juga boleh semak bahawa syarat yang diperlukan pada matriks ini dipenuhi dan itu hanya soal memasukkan matriks Krauss
ke dalam persamaan dan menilai dan kita mendapat matriks identiti seperti yang diperlukan untuk contoh lain jom tengok semula
saluran penyahfasa sepenuhnya mengambil matriks ket 0 bra 0 dan ket satu bra satu berfungsi dan itu boleh disemak dengan
mengembangkan jumlah dan melihat secara langsung bahawa kita mendapat apa yang kita perlukan dan sekali lagi syarat yang diperlukan dipenuhi
alternatifnya ialah mengambil a 0 sebagai matriks identiti dibahagi akar 2 dan A1 sebagai
sigma Z dibahagi akar 2 dan jika kita nilaikan kita lihat bahawa sekali lagi kita mendapat saluran penyahfasa sepenuhnya berdasarkan pemerhatian
WEBVTT
yang kita buat tentang saluran ini sedikit sebelum ini dalam pelajaran dan sekali lagi syarat yang diperlukan agak mudah untuk
disemak sebagai latihan untuk dikerjakan jika kau rasa itu membantu pertimbangkan saluran depolarisasi sepenuhnya
yang menghasilkan keadaan bercampur sepenuhnya untuk setiap input matriks ketumpatan untuk saluran ini diperlukan empat matriks Krauss
tidak mungkin untuk menghasilkan perwakilan Krauss di mana n adalah tiga atau kurang berikut ialah satu pilihan yang berfungsi dan
berikut ialah satu lagi jadi latihannya ialah untuk mengesahkan bahawa pilihan ini berfungsi serta menyemak bahawa syarat yang diperlukan
dipenuhi adalah worth pointing out bahawa alternatif kedua pada dasarnya mengatakan bahawa adalah mungkin untuk mendepolarisasi sepenuhnya qubit atau dalam erti kata lain untuk
mengacak sepenuhnya dengan memilih secara rawak salah satu daripada empat matriks Pauli termasuk identiti dan mengenakan
operasi uniter yang sepadan pada qubit dan jadi saluran depolarisasi sepenuhnya adalah satu lagi contoh saluran uniter
bercampur yang terakhir daripada tiga perwakilan saluran yang akan kita liputi ialah perwakilan Choi Man-Duen Choi
ialah seorang ahli matematik yang bekerja pada teori matriks dan topik lain dan perwakilan Choi dinamakan untuk menghormatinya
berdasarkan makalah yang sangat elegan yang diterbitkannya pada tahun 1975 yang dalam erti tertentu mengikat semua benda ini bersama perwakilan Choi
saluran fi adalah matriks tunggal yang secara konvensional ditandakan J fi dan khususnya jika
sistem input mempunyai n keadaan klasik dan sistem output mempunyai M keadaan klasik maka perwakilan Choi fi akan
menjadi matriks segiempat sama n kali m kali n kali m sebelum saya beritahu kau tepat bagaimana matriks itu ditakrifkan saya ingin menyebutkan beberapa
sifat utamanya yang memberi motivasi kepada perwakilan dengan cara yang mungkin tidak dilakukan oleh definisi sebenar itu sendiri sekurang-kurangnya pada
permukaannya pertama tidak seperti perwakilan Stinespring dan perwakilan Krauss perwakilan Choi
adalah apa yang dipanggil perwakilan setia yang bermakna setiap saluran hanya mempunyai satu daripadanya dan itu cukup penting
kerana ia mengatakan bahawa dua saluran adalah sama jika dan hanya jika perwakilan Choi mereka adalah sama jadi jika kau
ada dua penerangan saluran yang berbeza seperti dua perwakilan Stinespring yang berbeza atau dua perwakilan Krauss yang berbeza atau mungkin satu
daripada masing-masing dan kau ingin tahu sama ada ia sebenarnya saluran yang sama kau hanya boleh kira perwakilan Choi dan
semak sama ada ia adalah sama sifat kedua ialah ada syarat mudah untuk disemak pada perwakilan Choi yang benar jika dan hanya
jika kita ada saluran yang sah sifat itu tidak begitu istimewa kita boleh katakan perkara yang sama tentang dua perwakilan lain tetapi ia adalah sifat yang baik
untuk dimiliki walaupun begitu dan kita akan bincangkannya dengan lebih lanjut secara terperinci tidak lama lagi satu perkara lagi yang perlu diperhatikan tentang perwakilan Choi ialah walaupun kita
mewakili saluran dengan matriks matriks ini tidak secara langsung mewakili saluran sebagai pemetaan linear sebenarnya ia adalah
lebih semulajadi untuk mengaitkan perwakilan Choi dengan matriks ketumpatan yang mewakili keadaan tertentu
daripada memikirkan perwakilan Choi sebagai menerangkan pemetaan linear bagaimanapun adalah mungkin untuk memulihkan tindakan saluran daripada
perwakilan Choinya menggunakan formula yang cukup mudah tetapi ia tidak semudah pendaraban matriks biasa
itu cukup sebagai pembukaan jom sampai ke definisi sebenar katakan kita ada saluran fi dari sistem X ke sistem Y
dan andaikan bahawa set keadaan klasik sistem input X adalah Sigma kita tidak akan perlu merujuk kepada set keadaan klasik sistem output jadi
untuk definisi itu tidak perlu namakan yang satu itu perwakilan Choi fi kemudian ditakrifkan oleh ungkapan
yang ditunjukkan di sini di skrin kita ada jumlah yang berkisar ke atas semua keadaan klasik A dan B untuk sistem input dan kita
menjumlahkan ket a bra b yang di tensor dengan saluran fi yang dikenakan pada ket a bra b jadi
perwakilan ini ditakrifkan oleh formula dan ada beberapa cara berbeza yang kita boleh fikirkan tentang formula ini sebelum saya bincangkannya bagaimanapun biar saya
sebutkan bahawa kadang-kadang perwakilan Choi ditakrifkan dengan cara yang sedikit berbeza di mana pengaturan dua faktor tensor diterbalikkan bermakna
bahawa fi ket a bra muncul sebagai faktor tensor pertama dan bukan yang kedua tetapi dua cara berbeza untuk melakukannya adalah
setara sehingga simetri mudah ini tetapi apa maksudnya ialah apabila kau menggunakan perwakilan ini adalah idea yang baik
untuk menjelaskan pengaturan mana yang kau gunakan pengaturan ini adalah cara ia dilakukan dalam Qiskit dan ia juga lebih baik untuk
menerangkan perwakilan secara visual dari segi matriks blok jadi inilah yang kita akan guna untuk lebih tepat tentang penerangan matriks blok
jika kita andaikan bahawa set keadaan klasik Sigma terdiri daripada integer dari sifar sehingga n tolak satu
untuk sesetengah integer positif n maka kita boleh secara alternatif menulis J fi sebagai matriks blok seperti yang ditunjukkan di sini di
skrin dalam erti kata lain perwakilan Choi fi adalah matriks yang kita dapat dengan menilai fi pada setiap
matriks input yang mempunyai tepat satu entri sama dengan satu dengan semua entri lainnya sifar dan kemudian menyusunnya
ke dalam matriks dengan cara yang cukup semulajadi mungkin tidak jelas a priori mengapa kita ingin membentuk matriks seperti ini tetapi ia
ternyata sangat berguna satu perkara yang perlu diperhatikan ialah set yang mengandungi matriks ket a bra b apabila
a dan b keduanya berkisar ke atas semua integer dari 0 hingga n tolak satu membentuk asas untuk ruang semua matriks n kali n jadi jika
kau ada matriks ini maka kau pasti boleh menentukan apa yang fi lakukan pada matriks n kali n sewenang-wenang oleh kelinearan
khususnya dengan mengambil gabungan linear yang sesuai daripada blok jadi matriks J fi memang secara unik
menentukan fi sebagai pemetaan linear cara lain untuk fikirkan tentang perwakilan Choi saluran ialah
ia mewakili keadaan sebagai matriks ketumpatan apabila ia dinormalkan khususnya dengan membahagikannya dengan bilangan
keadaan klasik sistem input yang akan saya teruskan tanda dengan n huruf kecil ini akan sentiasa memberikan kita
matriks ketumpatan yang sering dirujuk sebagai keadaan Choi saluran berikut ialah cara ini berfungsi dengan lebih terperinci
bayangkan pertama bahawa kita ada dua salinan identik sistem input dan kita pertimbangkan vektor keadaan kuantum psi
yang dipaparkan di skrin yang mewakili apa yang dipanggil keadaan terbelit maksimum pasangan sistem identik ini
misalnya jika Sigma adalah abjad binari maka ini adalah keadaan fi plus tetapi kita boleh fikirkan tentang keadaan yang ditakrifkan secara analog untuk
mana-mana pilihan Sigma dan apa yang kita dapat adalah keadaan yang sangat terbelit dan sebenarnya ia seterbelit yang mungkin kau dapat
memandangkan pilihan sistem ini untuk mendapatkan perwakilan matriks ketumpatan keadaan itu kita darab vektor keadaan dengan transpos konjugatnya seperti biasa dan
inilah yang ia kelihatan dan akhirnya jika kita fikirkan tentang perwakilan Choi saluran yang dibahagi n maka kita lihat bahawa ia adalah keadaan yang
kita akan dapat jika kita kenakan saluran fi pada sistem kedua dalam bentuk gambar berikut ialah
cara ini kelihatan kita ada dua salinan sistem X dalam keadaan terbelit maksimum psi saluran fi adalah
dikenakan pada sistem kedua yang berada di bahagian atas dalam gambar rajah dan keadaan yang terhasil adalah keadaan Choi fi tentu saja kita biasanya tidak akan
memberikan nama yang sama kepada dua sistem yang berbeza seperti ini ia umumnya tidak membantu untuk memberikan nama yang sama kepada dua benda yang berbeza tetapi ia memang masuk akal
WEBVTT
dalam kes ini hanya untuk membuat perkaitan dengan perwakilan Choi ada beberapa implikasi yang boleh kita tarik serta-merta daripada cara melihat
perwakilan Choi yang pertama ialah kerana keadaan Choi adalah matriks ketumpatan dengan syarat fi adalah
saluran yang sah kita simpulkan bahawa perwakilan Choi fi mesti separa positif definitif ingat bahawa ia adalah
keperluan yang kita letakkan pada saluran bahawa ia sentiasa menukar matriks ketumpatan kepada matriks ketumpatan dan ini
hanyalah satu kes khas bagi ini implikasi kedua ialah jika kita mengambil keadaan Choi untuk mana-mana saluran fi dan
kemudian buang sistem output y maka kita mesti tinggal dengan keadaan bercampur sepenuhnya pada sistem input X itu kerana
mengenakan saluran pada sistem dan kemudian membuang sistem yang terhasil ke dalam tong sampah adalah setara dengan hanya membuang sistem asal ke dalam
tong sampah dan jika kita berbuat demikian dengan keadaan terbelit maksimum kita matriks ketumpatan yang kita tinggal dengannya
ialah matriks identiti dibahagi n atau dalam erti kata lain keadaan bercampur sepenuhnya untuk sistem X idea dalam istilah
matematik yang lebih formal ialah menggabungkan mana-mana saluran dengan surih pada sistem output mesti sama dengan surih pada
sistem input dan itu kerana saluran mesti mengekalkan surih berdasarkan hakikat bahawa ia adalah pemetaan linear yang
sentiasa menukar matriks ketumpatan kepada matriks ketumpatan apabila kita ada persamaan ini kita boleh hapuskan penyebut n
dari kedua-dua belah untuk mendapat syarat yang sedikit lebih bersih dalam kata-kata menjalankan surih separa pada sistem output
perwakilan Choi saluran mesti memberikan kita matriks identiti pada sistem input jadi ringkasnya perwakilan Choi
saluran sentiasa separa positif definitif dan jika kita surihi sistem output kita semestinya
tinggal dengan matriks identiti pada sistem input ternyata ini bukan sahaja syarat yang perlu tetapi
ia juga syarat yang mencukupi bermakna jika fi adalah beberapa pemetaan linear sewenang-wenang dan kedua-dua syarat ini kebetulan
benar maka ia mesti sebenarnya bahawa fi adalah saluran yang sah dan kita akan lihat mengapa itu berlaku menjelang akhir pelajaran
jom tengok beberapa contoh mulai dengan saluran penyahfasa sepenuhnya untuk mengira perwakilan Choi ia hanya soal
menilai formula saluran penyahfasa sepenuhnya membiarkan ket a bra b tidak berubah apabila a sama b dan jika tidak output adalah
sifar jadi suku dalam jumlah yang bertahan adalah yang di mana a sama dengan b dan hasilnya dinyatakan di
skrin menggunakan notasi langsung kita juga boleh melihatnya sebagai matriks blok Delta membiarkan entri pepenjuru tidak berubah dan menzirofkan luar
pepenjuru dan jadi kita tinggal dengan matriks yang mempunyai satu di sudut kiri atas dan kanan bawah dengan semua
entri lainnya sifar dan itu konsisten dengan ungkapan pertama untuk contoh lain jom pertimbangkan saluran depolarisasi sepenuhnya sekali lagi kita
boleh mulakan dengan menulis formula dan sama seperti dalam contoh sebelumnya kita tidak mendapat sebarang sumbangan kepada jumlah
apabila a tidak sama dengan b dan kali ini apabila a sama dengan b kita mendapat keadaan bercampur sepenuhnya dan kita boleh permudahkan itu untuk
mendapat setengah kali matriks identiti 2x2 yang di tensor dengan dirinya sendiri iaitu setengah kali matriks identiti 4x4
kita juga boleh fikirkan tentangnya dari segi matriks blok dan secara semulajadi kita mendapat keputusan yang sama dan sebagai
contoh terakhir jom pertimbangkan saluran identiti untuk qubit tunggal ia mudah berikut ialah formula dan sudah tentu
saluran identiti tidak melakukan apa-apa sama sekali dan kita boleh fikirkan tentang hasilnya sebagai dua kali matriks ketumpatan yang dikaitkan dengan keadaan fi plus dan itu
konsisten dengan apa yang kita jangkakan dengan memikirkan tentang keadaan Choi saluran ini dan berikut ialah ia sebagai matriks blok perhatikan khususnya bahawa perwakilan Choi
saluran identiti bukan matriks identiti ia adalah matriks ini kita dah lihat tiga cara berbeza
untuk mewakili saluran dalam istilah matematik iaitu perwakilan Stinespring perwakilan Krauss dan perwakilan Choi
dan kita juga ada definisi saluran iaitu saluran adalah pemetaan linear yang sentiasa
menukar matriks ketumpatan kepada matriks ketumpatan walaupun saluran dikenakan hanya pada sebahagian daripada sistem majmuk soalan yang sangat semulajadi dan sangat penting
untuk ditanya pada ketika ini ialah bagaimana kita tahu bahawa benda-benda ini semua setara misalnya bagaimana kita tahu bahawa setiap
pemetaan yang diterangkan oleh mana-mana satu daripada perwakilan ini adalah sebenarnya saluran yang sah dan bagaimana kita tahu bahawa kita tidak meninggalkan sebarang saluran
baki pelajaran ini menerangkan bagaimana semua ini boleh difikirkan secara matematik jika kau bersedia menerima kesetaraan benda-benda ini dan kau tidak berminat dengan bagaimana ia boleh
difikirkan maka kau bebas untuk melangkau baki video tetapi saya secara peribadi fikir hujah itu cukup
keren dan ia adalah contoh gaya tertentu bukti matematik yang muncul dari masa ke masa dalam teori maklumat kuantum saya tidak akan lalui
semua butiran sesetengahnya saya tinggalkan untuk kau atau kau boleh menemuinya dalam kandungan bertulis untuk pelajaran ini di mana segalanya ditulis dengan
terperinci tetapi saya berharap dapat menyampaikan gambar yang cukup jelas tentang cara semuanya berfungsi apa yang kita ingin lakukan ialah membuktikan
kesetaraan koleksi kenyataan dan cara kita boleh melakukan ini ialah dengan menyediakan kitaran implikasi khususnya kita akan mulakan
dengan definisi saluran iaitu pemetaan linear yang sentiasa menukar matriks ketumpatan kepada matriks ketumpatan
daripada definisi ini kita boleh berhujah bahawa perwakilan Choi saluran ini mesti memenuhi dua syarat yang telah
kita kenal pasti dan sebenarnya kita dah lakukan ini ini dibincangkan dalam konteks keadaan Choi saluran kita kemudian lupakan semua
tentang definisi dan kita bekerja dari perwakilan Choi dan memandangkan dua syarat kita pada perwakilan Choi kita simpulkan bahawa pasti wujud
perwakilan Krauss pemetaan fi kita kemudian melakukan perkara yang analog kita lupakan tentang perwakilan Choi dan kita bekerja
dari perwakilan Krauss sewenang-wenang dan daripadanya kita boleh berhujah bahawa pasti ada perwakilan Stinespring untuk pemetaan fi dan by the way hujah-hujah
ini akan bersifat mekanikal dalam erti tertentu yang membolehkan kita sebenarnya melakukan penukaran mengikut anak panah untuk saluran tertentu jika kita mahu
melakukan itu implikasi terakhir ialah berhujah bahawa jika kita ada perwakilan Stinespring untuk pemetaan fi maka
pemetaan itu mesti sebenarnya saluran yang sah dan sekali lagi kita dah lakukan itu kali ini dalam konteks perwakilan Stinespring
secara keseluruhannya empat implikasi ini mendedahkan bahawa empat benda ini semua setara kerana kau boleh mulakan dari mana-mana satu daripadanya dan
mengikuti implikasi secara transitif untuk sampai ke mana-mana yang lain kita akan mulakan dengan implikasi pertama
iaitu jika kita ada saluran fi bermakna pemetaan linear yang sentiasa menukar matriks ketumpatan kepada matriks ketumpatan maka ia mempunyai perwakilan Choi
yang memenuhi dua syarat yang kita kenal pasti sebelumnya iaitu ia adalah separa positif definitif
dan jika kita surihi sistem output kita mendapat identiti pada sistem input dan seperti yang saya sebutkan sebentar tadi kita dah
liputi implikasi ini dalam konteks keadaan Choi khususnya apabila kita bahagi perwakilan Choi saluran dengan n bilangan
keadaan klasik sistem input maka kita mendapat matriks ketumpatan dan tambahan pula keadaan terkurang
sistem input X bagi keadaan itu adalah keadaan bercampur sepenuhnya atau dalam erti kata lain matriks identiti dibahagi n menghapuskan penyebut memberikan kita
dua syarat kita jadi implikasi ini cukup cepat dan mudah kerana kita dah liputi
WEBVTT
ia sekarang jom tengok implikasi kedua kali ini kita mulakan dengan perwakilan Choi pemetaan yang
kita anggap memenuhi dua keperluan dan matlamat kita ialah menghasilkan perwakilan Krauss untuk pemetaan ini yang
memenuhi keperluan yang kita bicarakan sebelumnya implikasi ini cukup mekanikal dalam ertinya kita memerlukan sedikit
aljabar linear dan ia kebanyakannya akan bergantung kepada memanipulasi matriks dan vektor dengan cara yang cukup bijak
ia bermula dengan andaian bahawa perwakilan Choi adalah separa positif definitif yang merupakan yang pertama daripada dua keperluan yang kita anggap ada
konsep matriks separa positif definitif adalah penting secara asasnya dalam maklumat kuantum dan bukan hanya dalam konteks matriks
ketumpatan ia sangat kritikal di sini kita tidak akan dapat menjadikan ini berfungsi tanpanya khususnya andaian
bahawa J fi adalah separa positif definitif membolehkan kita menyatakannya dalam bentuk yang ditunjukkan di skrin untuk sesetengah pilihan
vektor psi 0 hingga psi N tolak satu dan sesetengah pilihan integer positif n dan biar saya nyatakan secara eksplisit bahawa ini adalah
bukan semestinya vektor unit satu cara kita boleh mendapatkan ungkapan seperti ini ialah daripada teorem spektral untuk matriks separa positif
definitif yang dibincangkan dalam pelajaran sebelumnya di sini kita tidak melihat sebarang nilai eigen yang muncul secara eksplisit seperti yang kita ada dalam penguraian
spektral tetapi ingat bahawa nilai eigen matriks separa positif definitif sentiasa nombor nyata bukan negatif dan perlu diingat bahawa kita
tidak memerlukan vektor psi 0 hingga psi N tolak satu ini untuk menjadi vektor unit jadi apa yang boleh kita lakukan ialah mengambil punca kuasa dua
nilai eigen dan mendarabkannya ke dalam vektor eigen unit yang kita dapat daripada penguraian spektral untuk mendapatkan
vektor psi 0 hingga psi N tolak satu sebenarnya tidak penting untuk bukti ini bahawa vektor ini adalah ortogon kita memang
mendapat itu daripada penguraian spektral tetapi kita tidak akan menggunakannya di sini dan jika kita ada ungkapan berbeza bagi J fi seperti ini yang tidak datang daripada teorem
spektral maka itu tidak mengapa kita sekarang menguraikan setiap vektor ini seperti yang ditunjukkan di skrin dan
ini adalah sama seperti yang kita akan lakukan jika vektor ini adalah vektor keadaan kuantum pasangan sistem XY dan kita
melakukan pengukuran asas piawai pada sistem X untuk jelaskan kita tidak mengukur apa-apa di sini kita hanya menulis vektor ini dalam bentuk ini yang
sentiasa mungkin dan sekarang tibalah triknya kita takrifkan matriks Krauss a0 hingga a n tolak satu dengan mengambil
ket A dari depan vektor psi 0 hingga psi N tolak satu membalikkannya supaya ia menjadi bra A dan bukannya
ket A dan meletakkannya di sebelah kanan seperti yang ditunjukkan dalam persamaan di skrin satu cara untuk fikirkan
tentang ini ialah kita pada dasarnya melipat vektor ini untuk membentuk matriks supaya jika kita susun Lajur AK di atas satu sama lain kita akan
mendapat semula psi k jadi matriks ini mempunyai tepat entri yang sama dengan vektor yang sepadan tetapi kita hanya
menyusun semula entri secara berbeza supaya kita mendapat matriks tetapi kita juga boleh fikirkan tentang matriks ini semata-mata secara simbolik dari segi notasi langsung
seperti yang ditulis di sini dan sekarang pada ketika ini ada soalan yang jelas mengapa ini sepatutnya berfungsi baik jom jangan terlalu lama memikirkan
mengapa ia berfungsi jom sahaja sahkan bahawa ia memang berfungsi untuk melakukan ini jom takrifkan pemetaan baru iaitu pemetaan yang ditakrifkan oleh
matriks ini di mana kita memperlakukannya sebagai matriks Krauss apa yang boleh kita lakukan sekarang ialah mengira perwakilan Choi
pemetaan baru ini dan kita akan lihat bahawa ia sama dengan perwakilan Choi pemetaan fi yang kita mulakan dengannya dan
kerana perwakilan Choi adalah setia ini bermakna dua pemetaan itu sebenarnya sama saya tidak akan lalui aljabar dalam video ini kau
boleh sahkan itu sendiri ia cukup mekanikal dan ia adalah latihan yang baik dan semua yang kau perlukan untuk itu ada di sini
di skrin kita belum katakan apa-apa lagi tentang dua syarat kedua dalam dua kotak tetapi ia
ternyata setara dan satu cara untuk menetapkan itu ialah mengesahkan persamaan yang dipaparkan di sini di bahagian bawah
skrin huruf T di sini by the way merujuk kepada transposisi matriks yang boleh kau fikirkan secara alternatif sebagai
pemetaan linear yang menukar ket a bra b kepada ket b bra a dan ia hanyalah sesuatu yang diperlukan untuk menjadikan formula berfungsi jadi
ringkasnya ada aljabar yang diperlukan untuk implikasi ini tetapi seperti yang saya katakan ia semua cukup mekanikal
pada dasarnya gimnastik indeks seperti yang sesetengah orang merujuk kepada jenis benda ini tetapi jika kau lalui dan kau berikan otak kau peluang untuk menyerapnya kau mungkin mendapati
bahawa kau mendapat pemahaman yang lebih baik tentang bagaimana perwakilan Choi dan perwakilan Krauss berkait implikasi ketiga membolehkan kita
pergi dari perwakilan Krauss pemetaan fi di mana syarat biasa ada kepada perwakilan Stinespring yang ini cukup
serupa dalam semangat dengan implikasi sebelumnya dalam ertinya ia mekanikal dan boleh dilihat dan disahkan dalam istilah aljabar semata-mata
ideanya sebenarnya cukup mudah apa yang boleh kita lakukan ialah mengambil matriks Krauss kita dan membentuk sebahagian daripada matriks yang lebih besar dengan menyusunnya
di atas satu sama lain seperti yang ditunjukkan di skrin apabila ia diisi penuh ini akan memberikan kita matriks uniter U untuk
perwakilan Stinespring matriks uniter mesti menjadi matriks segiempat sama jadi kita akan perlu mengisi seberapa banyak yang tinggal
lajur yang kita perlukan untuk melakukan itu tetapi ia sebenarnya tidak akan membuat sebarang perbezaan apa ia selagi kita mendapat matriks
uniter jika kita buat sementara waktu ketepikan kebimbangan bahawa U adalah uniter dan hanya fokus pada pemetaan linear yang ditakrifkan oleh
perwakilan Stinespring yang kita dapat dari matriks U ini maka apa yang kita dapati ialah pemetaan itu sama dengan
pemetaan asal fi yang ditakrifkan oleh perwakilan Krauss yang kita mulakan dengannya itu adalah bahagian lain bukti yang tidak akan saya lalui dalam video ini kau boleh
menemui butirannya dalam kandungan bertulis untuk pelajaran ini tetapi kau mungkin juga ingin mengambil masa dan mengerjakannya sendiri hanya ingat
seperti biasa untuk siri ini bahawa kita menggunakan konvensyen pengaturan ket untuk menafsirkan gambar rajah jadi w dan G akan
sepadan dengan faktor tensor di sebelah kiri dalam persamaan dan by the way jika kau
lalui ia kau akan dapati bahawa kerana kita ada ket 0 bra 0 sebagai faktor tensor di sebelah kiri dalam persamaan
yang perlu kita sahkan satu-satunya bahagian U yang ada relevannya ialah bahagian yang diberikan oleh matriks Krauss jadi selagi kita
mengisi lajur u dengan cara yang menjadikannya uniter maka kita baik tetapi ini sudah tentu memerlukan bahawa lajur yang dibentuk oleh a0 hingga a n tolak
satu apabila kita susunnya di atas satu sama lain adalah ortonormal dan di sinilah syarat yang kita letakkan pada perwakilan Krauss dimainkan
dan memang ia tepat setara dengan lajur yang menjadi ortonormal hubungan matematik yang berkaitan yang diperlukan untuk membuat
kesimpulan ini ditunjukkan di bawah di bahagian bawah skrin jadi teruskan dan jeda dan sahkan jika kau Pilih atau sekali lagi
rujuk kandungan bertulis untuk butiran lanjut ringkasnya apa yang berlaku di sini dalam implikasi ini dan dalam
yang sebelumnya ialah kita menerangkan operasi matematik yang sama dengan cara berbeza tetapi setara
Jantung Berdenyut bagi semuanya pada dasarnya adalah pendaraban matriks implikasi keempat dan terakhir menetapkan bahawa jika kita ada
perwakilan Stinespring untuk sesetengah pemetaan maka pemetaan itu mesti sebenarnya saluran yang sah dan seperti yang saya nyatakan
sebelumnya kita dah liputi implikasi ini apabila kita membincangkan perwakilan Stinespring ringkasnya dan dalam
WEBVTT
istilah yang sedikit berbeza memperkenalkan sistem ruang kerja yang diinisialisasi adalah saluran yang sah kerana menambah tensor matriks
ketumpatan tetap kepada matriks ketumpatan yang diberi sentiasa memberikan kita matriks ketumpatan dan ia adalah pemetaan linear oleh bilinearity
hasil darab tensor operasi uniter sentiasa saluran yang sah seperti yang saya bincangkan sebelum ini dalam pelajaran menyurihi sistem adalah saluran yang sah kerana
surih separa adalah pemetaan linear yang sentiasa menukar matriks ketumpatan kepada matriks ketumpatan dan akhirnya komposisi
saluran sentiasa merupakan saluran yang sangat mudah tetapi pasti patut diperhatikan tersendiri dan dengan
empat implikasi yang baru kita liputi kita telah menetapkan kesetaraan tiga perwakilan saluran kita bersama-sama dengan
definisi asal saluran khususnya kita mulakan dengan definisi saluran kita lihat bagaimana definisi itu menyiratkan bahawa perwakilan Choinya
semestinya memenuhi dua syarat asas kemudian kita lihat bagaimana syarat itu membolehkan kita mencari perwakilan Krauss yang seterusnya
membolehkan kita mencari perwakilan Stinespring dan akhirnya kita lihat bahawa kewujudan perwakilan Stinespring mendedahkan bahawa kita memang
mempunyai saluran yang sah sudah tentu ada butiran teknikal di dalamnya dan ia tidak semestinya mudah terutamanya
apabila kau melihatnya buat kali pertama tetapi apa yang menarik dan patut diperhatikan di sini ialah implikasi ini disediakan dengan cara yang memang
menjadikan benda semudah mungkin dan dalam matematik kau tidak perlu rasa malu dalam mengambil jalan yang mudah misalnya
tidak jelas sama sekali bahawa setiap saluran mempunyai perwakilan Stinespring atau perwakilan Krauss
tetapi adalah agak mudah untuk membuat kesimpulan bahawa perwakilan Choi setiap saluran memenuhi dua syarat yang telah kita kaitkan dengannya dan itu
membolehkan kita mengikuti laluan yang lebih kurang aljabar kepada dua perwakilan lain dalam garis yang sama implikasi
terakhir dari perwakilan Stinespring kembali kepada definisi juga agak mudah dan ia
membolehkan kita membuat kesimpulan bahawa kita hanya mendapat saluran dan tiada pemetaan lain daripada perwakilan Choi dengan syarat bahawa
syarat yang diperlukan dipenuhi dan seperti yang saya singgung sebelumnya cara kita berhujah implikasi ini cukup mekanikal untuk membolehkan kita dengan mudah menukar
antara perwakilan dan jika kau kembali kepada beberapa contoh yang kita liputi sebelum ini dalam pelajaran kau akan dapati bahawa ia memang mungkin untuk
menukar antara perwakilan kadang-kadang dengan cukup mudah dan terus dan itulah penghujung
pelajaran yang telah semuanya tentang saluran kita bincangkan apakah ia dan kita tengok beberapa contoh asas kita bincangkan tiga cara saluran boleh
diwakili dan kita menyelami beberapa butiran teknikal yang menetapkan kesetaraan perwakilan ini saya
harap kau akan sertai saya untuk pelajaran seterusnya yang semuanya tentang pengukuran dalam formulasi umum maklumat kuantum selamat tinggal sehingga jumpa lagi